monsieur pierre coppey président de
vinci autoroutes et mes chers collègues
donc nous poursuivons notre audition sur
les concessions autoroutières en
entendant aujourd'hui monsieur pierre
coppey président de vinci autoroutes qui
regroupe trois sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroutes historique asf cofiroute et
escota ainsi que a recours depuis 2005
monsieur copé a en outre été président
de l'association des sociétés françaises
d'autoroute entre 2012 et 2016
cette audition est diffusée en direct
sur le site internet du sénat
elle fera l'objet d'un compte rendu
publié
monsieur le président je vous remercie
de vous être rendu à notre convocation
et après avoir rappelé alors on est
vraiment dans l'informel la forme pure
forme de la commission enquête est prêt
vous avoir rappelé qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission denquête est
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434 13,4 134,14 434 15 du code pénal je
vais vous inviter à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
levé la main droite et dit je le jure je
le jure je vous remercie et sans plus
attendre je vais passer la parole à
notre rapporteur vincent delahaye
confirme un sens vous avez la part merci
monsieur le président bonjour monsieur
le président merci de 2 vous êtes rendus
disponibles pour cette audition
de cette commission d' enquête qui n'est
pas un procès des sociétés d'autoroutes
je préfère le dire tout de suite voilà
on est pas on est pas là pour dresser le
procès des sociétés d'autoroutes
on est là pour essayer d'y voir clair
sur l'historique l'historique nous
intéresse surtout pour éclairer l'avenir
parce que c'est surtout ça qui nous
intéresse et pour aussi dressé un peu
l'état des lieux aujourd'hui de la
gestion des autoroutes des relations de
l'état avec des sociétés
concessionnaires et puis d'envisager les
différentes possibilités pour pour
l'avenir et de faire en sorte que l'état
avec les futurs gouvernements soient
prêts quelle que soit la solution
la direction qui souhaiteront prendre à
ce moment là donc alors moi je vais je
vais commencer
j'ai pas mal de questions à vous poser
mais j'aime aussi partager la la parole
avec mes collègues donc je vais essayer
de pas trop trop long mais alors si je
reprends dans un premier temps plutôt
sur l'histoire
l'histoire dès l'ouverture du capital
notamment des asf en 2002 et puis la
privatisation en 2006 sur cette partie
là ce qui m'intéresserait c'est que vous
nous disiez un peu ce qui figurait dans
le pacte d'actionnaires avec l'état à
partir du moment où l'état ouvert
le capital des sociétés en 2002 qu'est
ce qui figurait dans le pacte
d'actionnaires entre autres le groupe
vinci et l'état à l'époque
ensuite j'ai des questions sur les plans
d'affaires puisque quand la
privatisation et lieu en 2006 il ya eu
des plans d'affaires qui ont été bien
sûr élaboré qui ont permis de déterminer
les cash-flows futurs et les flux de
dividendes ce qui a déterminé forcément
une valeur de des sociétés à l'époque
est ce que ces plans d'affaires
on était ont été respectées quoi est-ce
que les prévisions de l'époque se sont
réalisés et est ce qu'il y a eu des
écarts et dans quel sens et dans quelles
proportions
[Musique]
je souhaiterais aussi que l'on revienne
sur une question qui est très souvent
évoquée c'est la rentabilité des
sociétés d'autoroutes qui est parfois vu
de façon peut-être un peu restrictive
dont j'ai bien compris que les sociétés
d'autoroutes les bases et surtout sur le
taux de rentabilité interne le terry qui
qui évolue le terrain aussi en fonction
bien sûr du coût des capitaux et les
primes de risque qui existe et est ce
que est ce que sur ce terrain est ce que
pour vous il a évolué depuis depuis 2006
dans quelles proportions
et est-ce qu'aujourd'hui comme nous le
disent certains
la prime de risque on dit pas que le
reste a évolué mais elle risque
d'exploitation des hot hot
existe il existe et il est toujours là
mais est ce que la prime de risque elle
a pu évoluer selon vous c'est à dire
laisser la prime c'est ce qu'elles sont
prêts à payer des investisseurs puisque
on nous a beaucoup dit qu'il y avait
beaucoup d'investisseurs qui
s'intéressait à ses infrastructures en
france comme à l'étranger
mais qu'à partir de man il y avait
beaucoup d'investisseurs et beaucoup
d'argent prêt à s'investir forcément on
est prêt à payer moins cher la prime de
risque que si on est on est un peu seul
alors ça c'est une question sur le
terrain sur les tarifs
je voudrais savoir si la pratique du
foisonnement dont on nous a dit qu'elle
avait été pratiquée s'avère que le
foisonnement vous savez ce que c'est un
dire qu'il ya une augmentation moyenne
qui est prévu dans le contrat une
augmentation de tarif annuelle moyenne
est en fait on augmente de façon
différenciée en fonction des tronçons et
peut-être lé trafic sur ce tronçon dont
on augmente plus certains tronçons et on
monte moins d'autres trousseau donc est
ce que cette pratique a existé
est-ce qu'elle existe encore ce qu'elle
est encore pratiqué ou pas du tout voilà
alors c'est peut-être une première série
de questions que je compléterai après
parce que sinon ça va être un petit peu
long monsieur le président merci mon
cher vincent monsieur copé on va vous
donne la parole sur
ces éléments de première et vous allez
nous donner des éléments de vos
premières réponses sur les sujets
importants et marquant de cette
commission denquête allez-y merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
rapporteur
mesdames madame et messieurs les
sénateurs
j'ai compris que la règle du jeu
m'autorisait à un propos liminaire de
présentation est donc juste de ce droit
en vous remerciant d'abord de
l'opportunité que vous me donnez en
organisant cette cette audition je suis
salarié du groupe vinci où j'ai occupé
différentes fonctions depuis 1992 vinci
est le premier groupe européen et parmi
les tout premiers groupes mondiaux de
concessions et de construction et vinci
est né du rapprochement d'un grand
nombre de groupes de construction qui
ont en commun d'avoir tout au long du
xxème siècle développer leur activité
autour de différents modes contractuels
dont celui des concessions qui je le
rappelle consiste à concevoir construire
financer et exploiter des grands projets
d'infrastructures les plus connus et les
plus importantes sont les concessions
d'autoroutes qui nous réunissent
aujourd'hui mais je pourrais également
cité les parkings les aéroports la
concession du stade de france dont je
suis déjà venu parler ici la concession
de la ligne à grande vitesse tours
bordeaux où de nombreux projets de
moindre importance avec des
collectivités locales je suis le patron
de vinci autoroutes depuis 2009 et vinci
autoroutes regroupe 5 sociétés gérant
sept contrats dont la fin s'échelonnent
entre 2032 et 2086 cofiroute qui est
privé depuis sa création
asf qui a été
privatisée en 2006 après que son capital
et été ouvert en 2002 escota qui est la
filiale d'atf harcourt concession
l'autoroute a19 gagné en 2005
archos qui est le contournement de
strasbourg que nous avons gagné en 2017
et enfin nous gérons deux tunnels dans
les concessions sont adossées à nos
concessions l'un l'a 86 adossé à
cofiroute en région parisienne et
l'autre le tunnel de puymorens adossé à
vinci autoroutes c'est et 4443 km
d'autoroutes ses 415 diffuseur 6000
ouvrages d'art 100 millions de mètres
carrés de chaussée ces deux cent
soixante six aires de repos 187 aires de
service ces 34 parkings de covoiturage
et 320 gare de péage en 2019 cet
ensemble a réalisé un chiffre d'affaires
légèrement super à 505 à 5500 millions
d'euros et un résultat net de 1,7
milliard d'euros
nous supportons une dette de 18
milliards d'euros et nous sommes parmi
les tous premiers contribuables français
puisque nous avons versé plus de 1 8
milliard d'euros d'impôts l'an passé
sans compter le milliard d'euros de tva
collectée les concessions sont un outil
d'investissement et depuis la
privatisation nous avons investi 12 5
milliards dans nos concessions pour
construire des sections de nouvelles
pour élargir des sections existantes ou
pour améliorer leur performance
environnementale
ces investissements étaient prévus ou
bien dans nos contrats ou bien ajouter
par les contrats de plan le paquet vert
autoroutier le plan de relance
autoroutier de 2015 ou le plan
d'investissement autoroutier qui
représentait 430 millions pour vinci
depuis la privatisation nous avons
et j'ai plaisir à le dire à beaucoup
travailler l'amélioration de la qualité
de service aux usagers avec l'adoption
d'un contrat de services avec une
amélioration de la qualité des offres de
nos installations commerciales avec le
développement du télépéage nous avons
acquis des concessions dont le péage et
emmanuel et qui est maintenant
automatique avec une amélioration du
niveau de satisfaction des usagers qui
est mesuré chaque année par un institut
de sondage indépendant et je le dis
parce que c'était aussi la logique
industrielle des privatisations que
cette amélioration de la qualité et je
crois qu'on peut en souligner les
promesses et autant que la bonne
réalisation
je voudrais également dire que nous
sommes fiers de notre modèle social
puisqu'il nous a permis de faire face à
la révolution de l'automatisation du ps
sans licenciement que il nous a permis
d'atteindre un niveau de performance
remarquable en termes de sécurité de nos
salariés nous avons divisé par cinq
l'accidentalité sur nos réseaux et il
nous a permis de développer
l'actionnariat salarié et j'ai plaisir à
dire que 100% de nos salariés
bénéficient d' accord d'intéressement de
participation et son actionnaire du
groupe vinci
nous sommes également fiers de notre
politique environnementale puisque nous
avons investi dans la protection de la
ressource en eau dans la préservation de
la biodiversité et nous avons
sensibilisé nos collaborateurs et
l'ensemble de nos parties prenantes à
ces questions nous appliquons les
nouvelles normes environnementales qui
se sont multipliés et notre impact sur
l'environnement n'a cessé de s'améliorer
depuis la prise en charge de ces
concessions il ya maintenant plus de dix
ans pour citer un seul exemple nous
avons déployé sur le contournement de
strasbourg 13 cents hectares de mesures
de compensation sur une emprise de 280
hectares ce qui donne un rapport de
proportion
édifiant et puis nous avons proposé à
l'état le concept d'autoroute bas
carbone qui doit contribuer à la
politique environnementale de l'état
dont on aura peut-être l'occasion de
parler alors j'ai lu dans l'exposé des
motifs de cette commission une demande
de transparence et de contrôle
notre activité est probablement parmi
les activités économiques les plus
contrôlées de l'économie française par
l'état concédant via la direction
générale des infrastructures de
transports et de la mer par le conseil
d'état via la section des travaux
publics par l'autorité de régulation des
transports par la dgccrf par la
commission européenne et j'en passe elle
est également l'une des plus
transparents
elle est soumise à des réunions
régulières de suivi et l'obligation de
publier de très nombreux rapports les
marchés de travaux et de fournitures
nécessaires à l'exécution de la
concession sont attribués avec des
seuils de mise en concurrence qui sont
les plus bas de france après avis d'une
commission indépendante et le contrôle
de l'autorité de régulation des
transports aucun manquement
et j'ai plaisir à le dire à une
obligation contractuelle n'a été
constaté depuis 2006 vous m'avez demandé
de vous transmettre une série de
documents contractuels et financiers
j'espère que leur examen a permis
d'apporter des clarifications qui était
recherché par la commission et je me
tiens à votre disposition pour toutes
les précisions que vous souhaiterez
obtenir alors si vous voulez bien je
vais m'efforcer de répondre aux quatre
premières questions que vous m'avez posé
monsieur le rapporteur alors sur le
pacte d'actionnaires qui est qu'il y ait
l'état aux asf et qui avait été négocié
alors que sf était encore une société
publique après l'ouverture de son
capital et alors que vinci détenait une
vingtaine de pourcents du capital des
asf
il y avait
dans cette ambition il y avait dans ce
projet dans ce pacte d'actionnaires une
ambition industrielle claire on parlait
beaucoup à l'époque de l'importance de
constituer un leader français de porter
et d'ambition mondial et je me souviens
qu'il y avait à la fois des ambitions de
développement à l'international entre
vinci et asf qui se sont concrétisées
sur un certain nombre de réponses à des
appels d'offres il y avait également
l'ambition pour les deux signataires de
ce pacte de collaborer sur des sujets
d'exploitation comme les parkings pour
les poids lourds ou comme les moyens
paiement les moyens de paiement
dématérialisé tous ces sujets avait fait
l'objet à la fois d'une discussion
d'impact et ont été suivies entre 2002
et 2006 date de l'entrée dans le
périmètre des autoroutes du sud de la
france de de vinci
alors ensuite vous m'avez en deuxième
question posée là la question du plan
d'affaires qu'il est en effet président
vous pourrez nous transmettre ce pacte
d'actionnaires je pense pas qu'on l'ait
dans le dossier où je dois pouvoir
retrouver sa dans les archives du groupe
sans difficulté remercie sur le plan met
clairement ce pacte était un pacte à
porter industrielle avec une ambition de
développer les métiers de la concession
autoroutière de conserves entre vinci
autoroutes et qui n'existait pas encore
à l'époque mais qui était représenté par
cofiroute et les autoroutes du sud de la
france sur le plan d'affaires de 2005
vous me dites at il été respectée bien
sûr que non un plan d'affaires dans une
concession d'autoroute c'est une somme
d'hypothèses un plan d'affaires c'est un
ensemble d'engagements que prend un
concessionnaire d'investir de réaliser
des investissements des constructions de
tenir des charges et des
obligation d'exploitation de qualité de
service aux clients
je crois que ces obligations ont été
largement tenues et plus que tenu et
tous les rapports d'exécution du contrat
en atteste le plan d'affaires c'est
autre chose le plan d'affaires c'est un
ensemble d'hypothèses de trafic de
trafic pour les véhicules légers de
trafic pour les poids lourds
c'est un ensemble d'hypothèses
d'inflation et puis c'est une loi
tarifaires alors sur le trafic
le trafic juste après la privatisation
s'est effondrée je me souviens d'une
période très difficile qui est la
période qui a suivi la crise de lehman
brothers en 2007 où lé trafic des poids
lourds baissé de 20% et les taux
d'intérêts monte à 7% je me souviens
qu'à cette époque là nous avions nous
avions une grande crainte de liquidités
puisque nos recettes baisser et et nos
charges était fixé je me souviens que
nous avions souscrit à l'époque pour
conserver notre liquidité un fait une
émission obligataire dont le taux devait
être super à 7%
donc le plan d'affaires à ce moment là
était très en dessous et les 20% que
nous avons perdu en 2007 sur le trafic
des poids lourds
nous ne les avons retrouvés qu'en 2017
2018 mais quand je dis que nous les
avons retrouvés ça veut dire qu'en 2017
nous étions au niveau de trafic pl que
le plan d'affaires prévoyait en 2007
mais en 2017 il aurait dû être abondée
d'un an et demi pour cent par an pendant
dix ans donc nous sommes très en retard
sur le les hypothèses de trafic qui
avait dans le plan d'affaires
l'inflation a été nettement inférieur à
ce qui avait été anticipé parce que vous
savez que cette période coïncide avec
une période de baisse de l'inflation et
les taux d'intérêt ont de la même
manière bc donc que l'un dans l'autre
mais c'est la loi des concessions dans
une concession on a des engagements
fixes qui sont faciles à mesurer
et puis on a des hypothèses dans les
plans d'affaires dont on peut constater
que l'un dans l'autre ça finit par
atterrir à peu près sur un équilibre
mais ça on peut le constater à la fin de
la concession aujourd'hui nous sommes en
2020 nous parlons d'hypothèses qui ont
été signés et définie en 2005 2006 est
ce que je peux vous dire c'est qu'il y
ait des écarts à la hausse et à la
baisse et que au global on serait plutôt
en dessous des hypothèses qui étaient
dans le plan de 2005 qu'au dessus alors
sur la question de prendre la question 4
avant d'aller sur la question sur la
rentabilité sur la question des tarifs
vous m'interrogez sur le la question du
foisonnement la question du foisonnement
c'est une question qui a suscité
beaucoup de passion et beaucoup
d'incompréhension qui est en fait une
pratique est assez simple qui est
générale à tous les opérateurs de
transport ça consiste à considérer quand
on applique une augmentation moyenne sur
un réseau vous savez qu'en france il ya
quarante mille tarifs compte tenu du
nombre d' origine destination
alors on peut c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on
fait depuis 2008 appliquée de façon
uniforme les hausses tarifaires sans
aucune
des formations de la green on peut aussi
et c'est ce que font n'importe quel oui
je vais revenir s'étaient interrompus à
partir de 2008 est la suite d'un rapport
de la cour des comptes et à la demande
de l'état sans d'ailleurs qui est base
contractuelle
le foisonnement et pratiqué par tous les
opérateurs de transport et ça permet par
exemple de tarif et plus fortement
paris bordeaux que chartres nord
chartreux sud où le mans nord le mont
sud pourquoi parce que sur le mans nord
le mans sud vous avez des domicile
travail qui prennent le taureau tous les
jours et vous avez bien sûr avantage
leur offrir un tarif plus avantageux que
le poids lourd qui descend de pologne
ans au portugal et pour lequel le le
trafic et le tarif et est moins sensible
ça a été interdit à la demande de la
cour des comptes pour des raisons que
personnellement j'avoue ne pas
comprendre parce qu'elle y est à la fois
une logique d'aménagement du territoire
a favorisé les trajets courts au
détriment des trajets longs
il ya une logique de justice et une
logique davantage pour le domicile
travail ça a été interrompue
ça avait été présenté est valorisée dans
le business plan de la privatisation
comme une ressource importante de est un
élément de valorisation
ça a été interrompue j'ai à votre
disposition une fiche qui vous montrent
de façon tout à fait clair comment ça a
été interrompu à partir de 2007 2008 à
l'issue du du rapport de la cour des
comptes
donc de façon très claire cette pratique
vous m'avez demandé si elle existait
encore elle existe chez tous les
opérateurs de transport sauf les
opérateurs autoroutiers et moi monsieur
le président mais pour compléter un sur
sur les tarifs
ça veut dire que depuis 2008 moi j'avais
compris que c'était depuis 2011 mais
vous me dites coûts depuis 2008 il ya
plus de foisonnement et ça veut dire que
on applique le taux moyen de façon
uniforme sur tout les tarifs les 40
médailles dont on parlait
quarante miser sur toutes les
concessions d'autoroutes donc commandé
soirée société historique il ya trois
groupes
mais ça veut dire que on applique de
façon uniforme et dans ces cas là c'est
très facile à contrôler pour les
services de l'état mais parce que si si
si si il ya exactement le même
pourcentage par tous et c'est quand même
très très simple mais je ne sais pas
pourquoi ils prennent du temps pour les
contrôler c'est pour une raison simple
alors d'abord comme je témoigne sous
serment je voudrais faire attention à
pas dire deux choses inexactes et j'ai
retrouvé ma fiche et le foisonnement
était arrêter progressivement entre 2008
et 2010 il a été arrêté par asf p2r
sanef en
art et sa peine en 2008 et il a été
arrêté par cofiroute en 2010 voilà et
alors après on est toujours la règle est
celle que vous dites
après quand vous avez des tarifs très
bas que vous augmenté de 1,2 pour cent
ce qui devait être à peu près le mois
pour cent ce qui était le talent le laos
de l'année dernière vous avez des ronds
plus vous avez des arrondis et il faut
gérer des arrondis et du coup vous avez
des répercussions qui se jette mais je
vous confirme que corriger que vérifier
comme le fait la dgitm la dgccrf et la
rt1 une grille tarifaire doit pouvoir se
faire en aller une après midi avec un
tableur excel qui permet de regarder
l'application est là juste la bonne
application de la loi tarifs
donc tout ça se fait très simplement et
on vérifie maintenant je crois qu'on en
est à 4
décimales après la virgule et donc tout
ça se passe très simplement et mais de
façon très précise alors maintenant vous
m'avez interrogé en troisième lieu sur
la rentabilité des sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroutes et vous
m'avez demandé si le terry avait évolué
en fait vous me donnez l'occasion de
vous faire une réponse extrêmement
simple lorsque on achète ou lorsqu'on
investit dans une concession on s'arme
d'un enfant d'hypothèses et de
conviction avec souvent la foi du
charbonnier 1 quel sera le l'inflation
en 2030 quel sera le trafic en 2032
qu'elles seront le quel sera le prix des
travaux et on fait tourner un modèle
avec d'un côté les recettes et de
l'autre les engagements d'investissement
d'exploitation de maintenance du
concessionnaire entre les deux on met un
terry qui sur le papier est est en 2006
de 7 8% ce chiffre vous a été communiqué
c'est en tout cas le chiffre qui
correspondait à des hypothèses partager
il arrive que mes convictions soient pas
les mêmes que celles du concédant il
arrive que j'ai plus foi dans la
croissance du tarif ou du trafic pardon
que le concédant est donc monté arrive à
être différente
enfin à l'arrivée si on est d'accord sur
des hypothèses on est d'accord sur un
péri comment ce terry évolue-t-il je
n'en sais rien je vous donne rendez-vous
en 2032 pour vous dire ce qu aura été le
théorie d'escota ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que depuis cette période nous
avons énormément investi nous avons eu
des avenants qui
prévu ces investissements qui ont été
compensées qui par des tarifs qui parle
de l'allongement ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que nous avons eu des hauts
et des bas et des années avec de grandes
baisses de trafic d année avec une
hausse de trafic
aujourd'hui nous sommes en dessous et
aujourd'hui nous avons considérablement
investi et donc nous sommes encore payer
des promesses de rentabilité à venir et
donc le territ aujourd'hui je ne suis
pas en mesure de vous dire si la cinu le
réévaluer je considère que les
hypothèses ont beaucoup bougé par
rapport à ce qu'elle était en 2006 et
qu'elle bougeront encore en d'ici à la
fin des concessions jeux concerts que
l'un dans l'autre
tout ceci devrait donner un modèle qui
restera sur un équilibre comparable à
défaut d'être semblable mais je ne sais
pas vous dire et personne ne peut vous
dire quel est le terreau y adapte le
terry a date est un non sens vous avez
un terry théorique à la signature du
contrat vous constatez un terry à la
sortie vous pouvez dire comment ont
évolué les choses mais le calcul du teri
adapte n'a aucun sens il y avait en tout
cas c'est une hypothèse qui suit une
autre hypothèse
je pense que c'est important
effectivement de dire on n'a pas le
terreau et à date
on ne peut qu évaluer le terry à date on
peut l'évaluer par rapport à
rétrospective et pour qu'on connaît
l'historique qu'on connaît et aux
prospectives qu'on a aussi qui sont et
qui partent d'hypothèses comme on le
fait au début de la concession au début
de la concession vous faites sur la base
d'hypothèses sur la durée de la
concession ses 30 ans on fait des
hypothèses sur 30 ans et puis on sait
pas très bien ce que ça va donner mais
on essaie de faire quelque chose de
juste et on détermine intérêts moi je
pense qu'on peut calculer un terry entre
guillemets théorique aujourd'hui terre
que théorique par rapport à la
connaissance qu'on a des quatorze ou
quinze années qui se sont écoulées et
puis des 15 années à venir
les quinze années à venir on peut faire
des hypothèses aussi elles seront elles
sont sans doute un peu plus précise que
celle qu'on fait au début sur 30 ans
mais elles seront forcément aussi fausse
parce que il ya des choses qui varieront
donc ça sera forcément quelque chose
d'un peu théorique comme on l'a vu au
début mais on peut je pense moi en tout
cas
reculé quelque chose sur cette base là
bas je ne peux pas souvent de pardon je
peux constater l'évolution des
hypothèses
je peut en déduire si je suis en avance
ou en retard sur le plan de marche
c'est tout dire à porter alors j'ai
répondu et je dirais que nous sommes en
retard sur le plan de marche bien
oui eric bocquet a souhaité prendre la
parole et vous interroger le président p
merci c'est le président alors sur le
terrain justement il ya de moins en
moins d'1 connu maintenant à la date où
nous sommes
la concession est à mi-parcours grosso
modo et donc je me suis procuré un
rapport d'un universitaire qui a fait un
état des lieux des différents
concessionnaires d'autoroutes dont votre
groupe
et le constat est le même pour les trois
groupes le vôtre eiffage et puis abertis
les évolutions sont les mêmes bon ça
c'est peut-être à un ex mais sur le
chiffre d'affaires donc sur les années
2006 à 2010 est chiffre d'affaires en
hausse de 45,3 % 1
c'est valable pour votre groupe baisse
de charge personnelle de douze ennemis à
8% du chiffre d'affaires
hausse de la marge de 64 % à 72 4% et
également baisse des charges d'intérêts
mais ça vous l'avez évoqué si les taux
d'intérêts effectivement sont plutôt à
la baisse j'imagine que cela s'explique
ainsi alors quel commentaire cela vous
inspire ce qui a forcément une
corrélation entre par exemple la baisse
de charges de personnel et la hausse du
chiffre d'affaires au moins pour une
part voilà quelle analyse faites-vous de
de ce constat donc établi sur la réalité
chiffrée de 2,11 année douze années
deuxième question
le fameux rapport de l'autorité de la
concurrence 2014 qui a fait date qui a
marqué qui a dit des choses assez
franche et qui parle un moment donné
dans je cite juste un point d'un rapport
de force très largement déséquilibré
entre les concessionnaires automobiles
d'autoroute pardon et l'état quelle est
votre analyse est dessus troisième point
à l'occasion d'une audition la semaine
dernière l'interlocuteur que nous
entendions évoqué la réaction d'un
représentant de la fédération française
entreprise de travaux publics qui sont
au nombre de 8000 en france et qui
faisait le constat de très grandes
difficultés voire impossibilité
d'accéder aux marchés de travaux des
autoroutes dont vous avez la la gestion
c'était vrai également pour les autres
concessionnaires d'ailleurs justement
dans le rapport d'autorité de la
concurrence il ya des recommandations
qui ont été formulés à la fin du rapport
j'avais juste en citer une qui vise qui
contribuent à améliorer les conditions
de la concurrence recommandation numéro
10 institué au sein des groupes vinci et
eiffage des procédures tentant à
prévenir les échanges d'informations
entre les filiales autoroutières et les
filiales de travaux routiers est ce que
cette recommandation a été mise en
oeuvre par exemple et dernier point vous
évoquez le l'actionnariat du groupe
vinci donc effectivement les salariés
son tour une part actionnaire je crois
que c'est de l'ordre de 2,2
9 % fin si les chiffres que j'ai sont
exacts mais voilà et je vois que parmi
les actionnaires figurent info une
holding qatari est ce qu'elle est qu'est
ce qu'il en est exactement
d'ailleurs j'ai noté sur votre règne g
enfin à moins qu'ils soient faut que la
direction grands projets a son siège à
doha au qatar est ce que vous confirmez
ou est-ce que ça a évolué voilà voilà
mes questions merci bien merci merci
pour ces questions 1 précise bien
documenté mais résidant je vais vous
donner la parole pour apporter les
réponses précises à ses questions
l'ordre de grandeur des vous fait je
vais répondre dans l'ordre sur le
sénateur lors de vendeurs des chiffres
que vous indiquez d'un rapport
universitaire qui m'échappe f1 qui m'a
échappé j'espère que vous me
communiquerez ces chiffres ne me choque
pas l'augmentation du chiffre d'affaires
la proportion d'augmentation du chiffre
d'affaires me paraît cohérente avec la
montée en charge des concessions je sais
pas de quel permettront pas mais je
pense que c'est cohérent avec la montée
en charge des de la maturité des
concessions de développement du trafic
et probablement l'augmentation du
périmètre dont il est question
la baisse des charges la baisse des
charges était est complètement dans le
business plan dont vous parlez dans le
plan d'affaires dont vous parlez de 2005
et on la retrouve dans l'évolution de de
la marge
non il n'y a pas de corrélation entre la
hausse du chiffre d'affaires et la
baisse des charges
il y a un plan d'affaires et une
évolution de la rentabilité de la
société qui correspond à la courbe en j
peut on a eu de nombreuses occasions de
communiquer dont je vous ai donné
d'ailleurs une illustration dans les
documents que j'ai transmis à la
commission
la courbe en j 7 lacombe par laquelle on
commence par faire part lever du capital
le faire des dettes et faire des
investissements
puis on démarre une fois qu'on a mise en
service la concession son exploitation
est petit à petit
on commence gagner de l'argent ça
correspond gagner de l'argent pour
permettre de rembourser l'investissement
est de rembourser le capital et de le
rémunérer
puisque je rappelle que la particularité
d'une concession c'est de devoir
rembourser son capital sur la durée du
contrat
ce qui nous différencie de toutes les
sociétés commerciales et ce qui est la
principale cause d'incompréhension quand
on parle des profits des sociétés
concessionnaires
on oublie toujours que en réalité une
concession c'est un véhicule
d'investissement
c'est un véhicule d'investissement dans
l'objet est de construire un ouvrage et
dont le contrat permet de rembourser sa
construction pour qu'au terme du contrat
on est remboursé l'ensemble des dettes
des obligataires et du capital et que on
laisse l etat l ouvrage puisque l'état
en est propriétaire
à la fin de la concession le
concessionnaire n'a plus rien et s'il y
a des dividendes aussi élevé sur les
sociétés concessionnaires c'est qu'elles
doivent rembourser leur capital sur la
durée du contrat
on est un peu dans la situation d'un
propriétaire qui aurait construit un
logement pour un bénéficiaire et qui
devrait avec son loyer à la fois payer
les charges d'exploitation et de
maintenance et rembourser le capital
et à la fin du bail rendre l'ouvragé
dont il ne serait pas propriétaire
le fait la méconnaissance de cet aspect
là du schéma explique grandement
l'incompréhension qui nous entoure et
les polémiques qui nous entourent c'est
pour ça que je profite de l'occasion qui
m'est donnée pour le dire une société
concessionnaire
c'est un véhicule d'investissement c'est
un contrat de travaux publics et c'est
un contrat pendant la durée du qu'elle
vous devez rembourser l'ensemble de
l'investissement et à la fin duquel vous
n'avez plus que des souvenirs louvre âge
allant dans la main du concédant et il
ne vous reste en tant que
concessionnaire que les bons souvenirs
de la construction de l'exploitation et
de la maintenance de l'ouvragé
je le dis
parce que ça fait partie des sujets vous
me parlez de l'autorité de la
concurrence dans votre question suivante
c'est ce que n'avait pas compris
l'autorité de la concurrence lorsqu'elle
comparer les marges des sociétés
concessionnaires avec les marges des
sociétés industrielles une société
concessionnaire n'est pas une société
industrielle
c'est un contrat de travaux publics
c'est un véhicule d'investissement et
ces chiffres s'expliquent par ses
spécificités et si je si j'ai réussi à
vous convaincre de ça aujourd'hui je
suis très content d'être venu
alors vous m'interrogez maintenant sur
un des points les plus contestables du
rapport de l'autorité de la concurrence
qui à l'époque disait que le rapport de
force entre l'état concédant et les
sociétés concessionnaires étaient
déséquilibrés et ben je vais vous dire
monsieur le sénateur je suis d'accord
avec cette idée
le rapport de forces est extrêmement
déséquilibrée au bénéfice de l'état
c'est à dire que nous avons en face de
nous l'administration de la de
l'équipement du ministère de
l'environnement maintenant la direction
générale les infrastructures de
transports et de la mer nous avons en
face de nous les services du trésor et
les services de bercy
nous avons en face de nous le conseil
d'état qui examine chacun des actes
contractuel avec une particularité bien
française qui est que le conseil d'état
est à la fois juge du contrat et conseil
du gouvernement
dans le genre déséquilibre j'ai je crois
que l'on peut difficilement faire mieux
et puis nous avons l'ensemble des
contrôles parlementaires et l'ensemble
des contrôles des corps de contrôle de
l'état
donc je pense que si un déséquilibre
dans les relations entre les sociétés
concessionnaires et l'état il est au
bénéfice de l'état concédant après vous
me parlez
de la question de l'accès des pme à la
commande des sociétés concessionnaires
mois cette question me semble relever
des bonnes pratiques commerciales des
pme des travaux publics dont vous avez à
juste raison rappeler qu'elles sont très
nombreuses en france puisque il y a huit
mille pme dans les travaux publics en
france
je voudrais dire qu'il n'ya pas 8000
entreprises de travaux publics capables
de travailler sur les grands travaux
autoroutiers et que les grands travaux
routiers relève de la compétence de une
douzaine d'entreprises parce que ce sont
des activités qui sont à la fois très
technique très complexe et qui
requièrent des qualifications et des
savoir faire qui ne sont pas à la portée
de l'ensemble des entreprises
mais vous savez que la suite de cette
campagne des pme et du soutien et de
l'écho qu'elle a pu obtenir
nous avons été conduits à nous engager
et à attribuer aux pme une part des
travaux 2 du plan de relance autoroutier
qui est suivi par une commission qui se
réunit deux fois par an donc je crois
que après l'autre question est celle de
l'accès des entreprises liées aux
sociétés concessionnaires par un même
actionnariat et je crois que toutes ces
questions étaient résolues par d'une
part l'article 6 des cahiers des charges
des sociétés concessionnaires qui dès
2006 nous obliger à attribuer nos
marchés avec une commission des marchés
indépendante dans laquelle siègent des
représentants qui sont aujourd'hui
désigné avec validation et après accord
de la rt en présence en présence de la
dgccrf avec contrôle de l'autorité de
régulation des transports
donc je crois que à la fois la
transparence et l'accès des pme à la
commande des sociétés concessionnaires
est tout à fait
garantie vous me interrogé également sur
la recommandation numéro 10 du rapport
de l'autorité de la concurrence qui
consistait à établir des procédures au
sein des sociétés concessionnaires pour
éviter la circulation de vos seins des
groupes pour éviter la circulation
d'informations privilégiées dont on nous
faisait et soupçons ça m'a conduit
personnellement a demandé à mes
prédécesseurs qui était à ce moment-là
devenu dirigeant d'une entreprise de
construction routière de quitter le
conseil d'administration des autoroutes
du sud de la france donc oui nous avons
appliqué cette cette recommandation même
si je ne suis pas sûr que ça ait
beaucoup de d'importance compte tenu de
l'ensemble des garde-fous établi sur la
dévolution des marchés des sociétés
concessionnaires
alors ensuite vous me poser deux
questions concernant l'actionnariat du
groupe vinci je vous confirme que parmi
les actionnaires significatifs du groupe
vinci figure un actionnariat d'origine
qu'à paris je vous confirme également
que vinci construction grands projets
une joint-venture avec un groupe qatari
qui lui permet de réaliser des travaux
au qatar en revanche je
ne vous confirme pas que le siège de
vinci construction grands projets et au
qatar il est tard et mal maison ce que
vous avez vu au qatar c'est le siège de
la joint-venture entre vinci
construction grands projets projets et
qatari diar
merci monsieur le président pour des
réponses précises à jour mon cher eric
la parole va être jérôme bascher et
ensuite à christine lagarde qui nous
regardent qui est en vision mais d'abord
jérôme bascher jeune homme c'est
christine le regard je vais essayer de
pas dire trop de bêtises comme vous je
connais pas bien le terry à date
j'en ai fait deux trois dans ma vie je
crois et contrôler un certain nombre
d'investissements et de concessions y
compris en revanche ce que je connais
c'est comme vous les recettes et les
dépenses très basiquement êtes-vous en
avance au 31 décembre 2019
on va accepter des années 2020 et j'y
reviendrai au 31 décembre 2010 à fait
vous en avance sur votre plan d'affaires
en recettes
où êtes-vous en avance sur votre plan
d'affaires en dépenses et où l' inverse
parce que quand on est un terry sans
doute un peu en dessous on peut avoir
avancé des dépenses prévues dans le plan
d'affaires plus tôt et on dégrade son
théorie à date et on peut avoir inverse
des recettes en plus ou en moins et donc
il faut regarder donc je suis comme vous
moi je connais le bon argent qui
rentrent le bon argent qui sort en
argent de ma grand mère comme un conte
dit deuxième question qui est importante
pour moi dans les concessions il ya le
sujet des biens de retour équivalent
évaluer ce qui est pour moi un vrai
sujet où en êtes-vous de vos discussions
sur ce point là
deux petites questions jaillir annexes
mais vraiment un ex par rapport au sujet
qui nous occupe est ce que deux
décisions administratives impacterait
fortement votre plan d'affaires est ce
que vos contrats seraient modifiées si
on passait à 110 km/heure sur les
autoroutes
si par exemple une décision de fermeture
de l'économie administrative arrivé en
2020 oui par exemple on appellerait ça
le confinement est ce que cela
du coup un pacte vos contrats parce que
vous n'avez pas forcément le même
produit est la même je dire
compétitivité peu d'eux des produits que
vous construisez et exploiter
corrélativement une toute petite
question est ce que le nombre de
passages aux péages est toujours un
indicateur avancé de l'économie
merci jérôme donc que monsieur le
président je vais vous donner la parole
pour apporter des réponses à notre
collègue vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le sénateur pour ces questions
sur la question est ce que nous sommes
en avance sur les recettes est en avance
sur les dépenses honnêtement si je fais
le calcul si je reprends le plan
d'affaires de vous m'avez posé la
question à fin 2010 9
si je fais le l'analyse des recettes à
fin 2010 9
j'évalue effectivement que nous sommes
significativement en retard sur les
recettes
mais je pense que nous avons été de bons
gestionnaires et que nous avons réduit
nos différentes charges ne s'est pas à
l'échelle sur les biens de retour j'ai
vu que cette question avait l'air de
susciter de la suspicion moi je pense
que cette question peut occuper les
juristes jusqu'à la fin des temps je
pense que c'est un sujet de thèse vous
avez les biens de retour les biens de
reprise et les biens propres
ça c'est un bien propre c'est sur le
les chaussées les ouvrages sont des
biens de retour
les biens de reprise personnellement je
pense qu'il y en a pas beaucoup et je
pense que d un concessionnaire et un
concédant désireux de se mettre d'accord
peuvent régler le sujet assez rapidement
après il ya la question l'état des
ouvrages qui est je crois très bien
réglée par les indicateurs de suivi des
chaussées des ouvrages et de l'ensemble
de nos ouvrages donc si vous voulez en
théorie une concession
c'est un acte de partenariat et un
contrat de confiance
et dans ce cadre là je pense que c'est
question se règle très simplement après
en théorie juridique on peux et je crois
que cela existe faire des thèses des
antithèses et des contres aux thèses
mais je crois que le sujet se réglera
assez facilement
j'ai d'ailleurs vu avec plaisir que le
président de la section et travaux
publics partager avec moi cette
conviction au moins celle là nous avons
au terme du en application du contrat
transmis dès la fin 2006 un inventaire
des ouvrages pour préparer ce travail et
nous avons dans le contrat une clause de
rendez vous je crois sept ans avant la
fin des concessions donc on a le temps
on a le temps de lire des thèses on a le
temps de se préparer et de se faire
confiance ou de mesurer en tout cas les
points de divergence il s'il devait y en
avoir mais je pense que c'est un
processus qui se passera de fans de
manière contradictoire est au fond assez
assez simple vous m'avez demandé
l'impact du confinement et je vous
remercie de cette question qui va me
donner l'occasion de vous dire combien
je suis fier de la manière dont les
gestionnaires de services publics
délégués que nous sommes ont fait une
démonstration de service public exemple
nous avons assuré la continuité du
service public pendant les pires jours
du confinement
nous avons assuré la qualité la
continuité l'efficacité nos
collaborateurs étaient sur le pont en
continu et ont assuré d'une façon qui
était je crois remarquable qui a été
saluée comme la contribution de la
deuxième ligne vont assurer la
continuité du fonctionnement de
l'économie française et des
approvisionnements à un moment où
c'était particulièrement difficile et à
un moment où toute l'économie était été
mise à rude épreuve
donc merci de me donner l'occasion de
saluer le travail qui a été fait il
était dû ce qui n'était pas du c'est ce
que nous avons fait d'assistance auprès
des poids lourds qui était sûr
[Musique]
les réseaux concédés et auquel nous
avons alors que les installations de
restauration étaient fermées par
décision administrative
nous avons organisé des distributions
gratuites de repas chauds pour les
camionneurs pendant cette période et je
pense que nous avons également organisé
des systèmes de dialogue avec radio
vinci autoroutes avec les poids lourds
et des échanges sur les réseaux sociaux
qui ont je crois
assurer un peu de bonne humeur et de
réconfort dans cette note qui était qui
était particulièrement difficile
après l'impact du confinement sur
l'économie de la concession
il est comme l'impact du confinement sur
l'économie française c'est à dire que
nous avons connu un effondrement des
trafics pendant toute la phase la plus
forte de du confinement puisque nous
étions à -80% de trafic vl voire 90 95
au plus fort du confinement est à - 40
au plus deux pour le trafic pl
au plus fort du confinement donc oui
nous avons eu une très forte baisse de
chiffre d'affaires nous avons eu une
forte baisse de trafic et nos chantiers
se sont arrêtés au rythme des annonces
de président de la république des
entreprises sont repartis dans leurs
foyers et les ouvriers se confiner nous
avions à ce moment-là 73 chantier je
vous ai dit que nous investissions cette
année de l'ordre de 800 millions d'euros
sur nos différents chantiers
ça représente 60 ça représentait le 17
mars 73 chantier et nous avons fait un
très long travail de remise en route de
nos chantiers avec l'établissement des
mesures barrières avec la modification
du confinement fin des des installations
de
du personnel des chantiers avec
l'organisation des mesures barrières
l'organisation des postes de travail et
l'ensemble des mesures sanitaires qui
modifie les postes de travail
ça a été difficile mais j'ai plaisir à
dire que la fin du mois de mai nous
avions relancer 100% de nos chantiers en
application des protocoles sanitaires en
application du protocole de l'oppbtp et
en ayant négocié chantier par chantier à
la fois les conditions sanitaires et les
conditions de l'exercice de de nos
entreprises
les conséquences de sa les conséquences
sont manifestement d'induire des
surcoûts sur la construction de nos
projets j'ai reçu il n'y a pas très
longtemps de du directeur général des
infrastructures de transports et de la
mer la circulaire que le premier
ministre a signé je crois le 8 juin
en joignant les maîtres d'ouvragé
publics à un comportement responsable
vis-à-vis des entreprises
j'avais un petit peu anticipé sur cet
état d'esprit en disant aux entreprises
avec lesquelles nous contractons et dont
nous sommes maîtres d'ouvragé redémarre
on dépêchons-nous de remettre en route
la machine et on discutera après donc on
a redémarré dans une logique de
confiance qui est celle que nous
essayons d'installer avec les
entreprises dont nous sommes maîtres
d'ouvragé attend maintenant des
discussions avec l'état qu'elle soit
placée sous le même sous les mêmes
auspices est dans le même état d'esprit
pour la prise en compte des
modifications d'exercice dvd travaux
publics que nous avons réalisés et vous
me demandez si le
pour finir si les passages aux péages
sont toujours un indicateur avancé de la
croissance économique et je crois que
oui même s'il ya des décalages même s'il
ya des distorsions même si on voit un
certain nombre de dévolution liée
notamment à l'évolution du du prix des
carburants
et j'ai l'impression que depuis quelques
jours il ya comme un frémissement ou en
tout cas une hirondelle dont je ne sais
pas si elle fera le printemps mais en
tout cas où l'été mais en tout cas j'ai
le sentiment que le trafic va moins mal
depuis quelques quelques jours ce sont
des données qui seront communiquées en
temps utile par le haut et vinci pour
respecter les règles de communication
financière mais disons que nous avons
annoncé la semaine dernière lors de
l'assemblée générale des actionnaires de
vinci que le trafic était autour de
moins 25 alors qu'on venait de -70 et je
pense que la tendance est à
l'amélioration se peut au moins dire ça
aujourd'hui j'ai le président merci
monsieur président ou petites précisions
de la part de notre rapporteur
oui écrit christine lagarde à m'excuser
mais je voudrais juste enchaîné sur le
sur les prévisions là puisque ça faisait
partie des questions que je m'étais
réservé pour la suite mais alors au delà
de ce que vous venez de nous dire
vous avez quand même une prévision pour
l'année 2020 on vous l'a demandé
d'ailleurs je vous remercie des
documents et des informations vous avez
pu nous transmettre jusqu'à présent mais
je vous ai redemander donc ces
informations a semaine dernière donc
c'est normal qu'elle soit pas encore ne
soit pas encore parvenu mais quelles
sont vos prévisions pour l'année 2020
est ce que en termes de chiffre
d'affaires vous perdez plus de deux mois
je vais estimée à deux mois la perte de
chiffre d'affaires global
les dix 81% pour les poids lourds c'est
45 % est ce que à la fin de l'année vous
pensez que on sera plus de deux mois de
pertes de chiffre d'affaires
est ce que vous pensez
avoir des résultats
positif ou faire une perte pour
l'exercice 2001 qui sera quand même noir
un peu partout et est ce que ça sera un
exercice noir pour les sociétés
d'autoroutes ou est ce qu'elle sera ça
sera moins bon exercice mais est est ce
que le trafic
combien de temps vous pensez
vous estimez
que le trafic reviendra à la normale
entre guillemets au trafic 2019
est-ce que ça va prendre un an deux ans
qu'est-ce que comment vous estimez et
qu'elles sont voilà j'imagine que vous
avez recadrer un peu vos prévisions
d'ici la fin du des concessions parce
que je pense que vos services même si
vous considérez tenté équipe vis-à-vis
de l'état ce dont je vous laisse la
responsabilité mais moi je ne suis pas
je n'en suis pas archi convaincu ce que
c'est pas tous les services de bercy qui
suivent les autoroutes
je vous dit tout les services de bercy
mais quand on regarde un petit peu
derrière c'est pas ça fait quand même
loin d'être tous les services de bercy
mais ceci étant j'imagine que vous avez
fait des prévisions
est-ce que coco comment comment vous
anticipez tout cela et quelles
conséquences ça effectivement sur la
rentabilité de vos contrats alors
monsieur copé allez-y je vous confirme
que 2020 est une année noire
je vous confirme que lorsque nous avons
connu en 2008
l'épisode de lehman brothers vous ai dit
tout à l'heure que nous avions mis dix
ans à retrouver le le trafic poids
lourds que nous avions à l'époque je
vous confirme que ce qui s'est passé
depuis le 17 mars aura un impact
significatif sur nos plans d'affaires et
je vous confirme que pour être qu'on
fait concessionnaire il faut avoir
confiance dans l'avenir et nous pensons
que sans qu'il me soit possible de faire
des hypothèses skis aux rares
confinement est ce qu'il y aura je ne
suis pas capable aujourd'hui de dire
dans quel cadre
dans quel schéma d'hypothèses sanitaires
nous nous inscrivons mais j'aurais
tendance à dire et à espérer que le
trafic sur l'autoroute reviendra
rapidement pour les vl et ne prendra pas
trop de temps pour les pl contenu
des relances et des efforts attendus de
soutien à l'économie mais ça m'est
difficile de vous dire plus et saufs à
enfreindre les règles de la
communication financière
je ne peux pas vous donner aujourd'hui
les hypothèses d'atterrissage de fin
d'année qui serait sont de toute façon
fausse puisque savard et tous les jours
je vous ai dit que la semaine dernière
on était à moins 25 et qu on avait
indiqué ce chiffre je vous ai dit que
les choses allaient moins mal
je ne sais pas comment elles iront la
semaine prochaine parce qu'il suffit de
6 mai alors j'imagine qu'effectivement
vous avez estimé des prévisions quand on
fait des prévisions quand on fait un
budget nous nous donne aux collectivités
ont fait des budgets mais forcément les
budgets ici ils sont paralysés à l'euro
près et on a toujours des surprises il
ya des choses qui sont en plus en moi ce
que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
est-ce que vous pouvez pas être comme un
tout petit peu plus précis même sens
sans enfreindre les règles de la
communication financière
est ce que quand même sur l'année
vous dites que ça repart assez vite sur
les véhicules légers donc je vous ai pas
dit que je vous ai dit que ça bc - c'est
pas pareil
plus le prémice à rome le trafic est
toujours négatif par rapport à ça de
pareille époque en 2019 tout à fait mais
je vous dirai rien de plus en suis navré
je me mettra en contradiction avec les
règles de communication financière merci
monsieur poser à lorient une petite
avant de donner la parole à madame
labarde
c'est pas cher et fait une allusion 110
km heure est-ce que vous avez c'est
nouveau ça vient de nous arriver c'est
sur le tapis ou est ce qu est ce que
cette idée va prospérer on ne sait pas
mais voilà il y avait cette petite
question en plus de monsieur ben asher
moi ce que je crois c'est que d'abord il
faut pas demander aux concessionnaires
de s'exprimer sur des décisions qui
appartiennent à la puissance publique
nous exécutons les politiques publiques
et nous n'avons pas vocation
nécessairement à les commenter ce que je
peux dire en tant que opérateurs
autoroutiers c'est que je pense que le
principal déterminant du recours à
l'autoroute et de l'utilisation de
l'autoroute par les usagers c'est le
temps gagné ce que je peux dire en
inscrivant mes pas dans ceux de la
ministre de l'environnement qui a dit ça
hier c'est qu'il faut se garder des
visions parisienne de ces questions se
souvenir du débat qui a eu au moment du
80 km/heure et penser tous les
navetteurs où les pendulaires qui chaque
matin prennent l'autoroute pour aller
travailler
je rappelle que les trois quarts des
trajets domicile travail se font en auto
que neuf trajet sur dix se font par la
route et que quand on limite la vitesse
on a certes un impact sur la sécurité
routière est certes un impact sur
l'environnement qu'il est difficile à
mesurer puisqu'on peut induire aussi des
reports de trafic sur le réseau routier
national
et donc je dis une fois que que j'ai dit
ça je pense que c'est une décision
compliquée lourde de conséquences qu'il
ne m'appartient pas de commenter au delà
de ce que je viens de dire
en tout cas merci ces éléments de
réponse bien madame la marquise à
christine vous avez la parole oui merci
monsieur
alors moi on va essayer de stabiliser le
sont pour l'instant il est très mauvais
starmine aussi oui qualifié fait d'un
contre non c'est vrai qu'on est ce qu'on
a un autre moyen d'avoir christine
lagarde par téléphone ou par on essaye
par téléphone christine en en attendant
entendant vraiment très mal le
rapporteur des voulait prendre le relais
en attendant stabilise et amy tabac le
son est toujours très mauvais on sait
qu'il ya des micro coupures très
importantes comment fonctionne et
l'occupation des aires d'autoroutes et
si j'allais à les concessionnaires
d'autoroutes étaient intéressés aussi ça
le président faut bien trop demander à
christine de reformuler s'ils sont à
meyer s
christine est vraiment désolé le son est
très mauvais et on a compris qu'il y
avait une question qui mettait laquelle
quelle est la relation entre les
concessionnaires d'autoroutes et les
prestataires de services sur les aires
de repos ainsi j'ai bien compris c'est
une question qui te tiens
à coeur mais on a vraiment très peu
entendu donc en a entendu ça est ce que
en effet un nouvel essai pour savoir
pour voir si le son s'est stabilisé
alors malheureusement il n'y a plus de
sens oui un problème de connexion donc
je président reprendre quelques quelques
questions
complémentaire que j'avais noté
effectivement alors bon je reste je
reste sur ma faim sur les prévisions
2020 à ce stade même si même si je
comprends je comprends ce que vous dites
qu'il ya la communication financière
j'aurais revenir quand même sur le
protocole 2015 protocole 2015 de liées
au plan de relance autoroutier 1,3
milliard deux cents millions de travaux
supplémentaires des rallongements de
deux concessions de durée de concession
des évolutions de tarifs qui était lié
aussi au à la décision unilatérale du
gouvernement de l'époque de geler les
tarifs pour l'année 2015 un de geôliers
de façon unilatérale les tarifs pour
l'année 2015
est ce que vous considérez que les
compensations obtenues par rapport à ce
gel de tarif
couvre couvre la perte que vous avez eue
en 2015 par rapport à une augmentation
des tarifs
à l'époque qu'est ce qui dans la
négociation de l'époque qui a décidé du
taux d'actualisation de 8%
puisque l'état proposait 6 8% que les
services de l'état proposé 6 8% de
mémoire et au dernier moment où en tout
cas sûr
au final le taux de 8% a été retenu est
ce que vous avez souvenir de qui 2 qui a
proposé qui a entre guillemets à poser
ce taux qui n'était pas celui du
concédant en tout cas pas la volonté du
concédant donc est-ce que qu'est-ce qui
est qu'est-ce qui a fait que ça a pu
arriver cela et puis une autre question
sur le loto de l'autorité de régulation
des transports
le fait que l'art affaire a été
transformée à cette époque-là en
autorité régulation des transports et
avec la compétence autoroutière est ce
que pour vous c'est une amélioration est
ce que c'est un bon interlocuteur est ce
que c'est une autorité avec laquelle
vous travaillez bien et comment
jugez-vous à la ce
les relations et le travail de cette
autorité merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le président monsieur copé
merci de deux de ces questions sur le
rapporteur est ce que le lac on est ce
que je considère que la compensation du
gel tarifaire a été bien fait
elle a été fait avec les mêmes
hypothèses de calcul que celle qui avait
conduit à l'augmentation avant le gel
donc je considère que oui ça a été fait
de manière équitable et j'ai pas
d'autres commentaires à faire sur la
compensation du gel de 2015
jeudi les tissages excusez moi parce que
la rtg justement que serait qu'à ce jour
poser une question ensuite chiffre à 500
millions d'euros le coût pour les
usagers de cette ce geste à dire que les
usagers finalement avec le rattrapage
sur les années
suivante la 2019-2020 deux fois où j'ai
pu c'est exactement si c'est ça 2023 et
la rta calculé que c'était un coût de
500 millions d'euros supplémentaires
pour les usagers est donc temps
nullement en faveur des sociétés
d'autoroutes parce que c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas l'état qui bénéficie de
ses 510 alors ça je pense que c'est le
plus désagréable des malentendus qui ait
eu dans la période récente fin en fait
leur affaire à cette époque commencé sa
mission
je pense qu'il ya eu dans la
compréhension de ces questions une
erreur de calcul de la raf est gelée
d'ailleurs écrit au président romand à
l'époque quand on calcule une
compensation on l'a fait avec un
ensemble d'hypothèses
si ensuite on n'applique pas cette
compensation et qu'on veut la rattraper
il faut reprendre les mêmes hypothèses
si vous prenez des hypothèses
différentes escales fait leur affaire
vous arrive est évidemment un résultat
différent et en l'occurrence leurs
affaires a dû décaler d'un demi point un
taux d'actualisation sachant qu'on parle
d'un impact sur un chiffre d'affaires
qui est de 10 milliards fois 20 ans et
donc si vous décaler d'un demi pour cent
ou d'un dixième un taux d'actualisation
sur 200 milliards vous arrivez à 500
millions mais c'est un chiffre absurde
et gelé contesté et je les écris à leur
affaire et je pense que elle nous en a
donné acte depuis donc je considère que
lorsque le colonel a été compensée il
l'a été dans des conditions tout à fait
équitable et neutre pour le pour
l'usager ensuite vous m'interrogez sur
qui a décidé du terrain
du plan de relance de 2015
c'est un projet qui a été discutée entre
l'état représenté par le ministère des
finances et le ministère de l'équipement
et les sociétés concessionnaires qui
avaient désigné un négociateur qui est
en la personne de bruno angles que vous
avez interrogé ces sujets ont fait
l'objet de business model de plan
d'affaires et ont été discutés on a
trouvé l arrivée un point d'atterrissage
qui est celui que que vous dites c'est
le fruit d'une négociation et je crois
que c'est le point d'équilibré entre les
différentes composantes de cette
négociation
après vous m'interrogez sur le jugement
que je porte sur sur leurs affaires et
sur le travail fait par l'art à faire
depuis depuis 2015
moi je constate que nous avons depuis
que la compétence autoroutière est au
nombre des compétences de contrôle et
non pas de régulation dollar à faire
transmis énormément de d'indications et
d'information alors à faire jeudi
autorités de contrôle et non pas de
régulation parce que je pense que c'est
important de ne pas introduire une
confusion sur ce sujet un contrat de
concession c'est un actif dont on peut
contrôler l'exécution mais c'est pas un
actif dont on peut réguler les
paramètres faute de quoi c'est plus un
contrat et une concession est un actif
régulé ces deux sujets différents
et quand vous regardez la loi la loi
confie à la raf est une mission de
contrôle de contrôle de la dévolution
des marchés et de contrôle
du fonctionnement les installations
commerciales ainsi que de suivi de la
rentabilité des sociétés
concessionnaires
c'est ce qui avait résulté des débats de
la loi de 2015 sur la modernisation de
l'économie
moi ce que je peux dire c'est que nous
avons transmis à l'ars à faire une
quantité très considérable
d'informations qui est je crois a été
instruit par l'art à faire ce que je
peux dire c'est que nous avons transmis
tous nos marchés
je suis personnellement très
impressionné par la quantité de données
que cela représente et pour tout vous
dire un peu perplexe sur l'utilité de ce
travail de contrôle parce que qui
connaît une concession c'est que le
concessionnaire prend le risque des
travaux et s'engage sur une évaluation
est au fond le prix auquel il réussit
réalise les travaux c'est son risque et
c'est son succès ou sow et son échec
mais ça n'a aucun impact sur le péage et
aucun impact sur l'usagé aucun ce
président là je ne peux pas vous laisser
dire cela aux jurés de se dire la vérité
mais en réalité quand on fait des
estimations sur 3 milliards de et qu'en
face on met des augmentations de tarifs
qui permettent de contrebalancer ces 3
milliard 2,6 vos travaux au final font 2
milliards 5 parce que les estimations
n'était pas bonne et que l ont été
surestimés alors si elles sont toujours
sous-estimé je suis d'accord série c'est
un gros risque pour le concessionnaire
mais si elles sont toujours su rester
mais c'est plutôt dans ce sens inverse
donc si on a une surestimation de nos
estimations ont fait payer plus par
l'usager à travers le tarif il faut pas
dire que ça n'a pas de conséquence sur
non ce que je dis c'est pas mal compris
aller au stade de l'évaluation des
hausses à de l'évaluation pour
construire un objet hier un échange
contradictoire entre l'état concédant la
dgitm et les sociétés concessionnaires
cet échange contradictoire est ensuite
soumis à l'expertisé de l'art à faire
dans le cadre du pays il y avait une
grande divergence qui a conduit l'état à
demander à un bureau d'études suisse de
faire une contre expertise de la
contre-expertise de là
affaire et qui aboutit finalement à un
troisième une troisième évaluation
ce que je dis c'est que oui on peut
imaginer que l'évaluation des sociétés
concessionnaires confrontée à celle de
la dgitm vérifié par celle de la raf et
on peut imaginer qu'on aboutit qu'on
aboutisse à un prix raisonnable mans
juste ce que je dis c'est que le
contrôle des marchés et le contrôle des
conditions d'exécution de ces
estimations n'a au fond pas d'impact sur
les tarifs et sur l' équilibre que
vérifie la con c'est leur affaire et
donc je dis que ça n'est pas un travail
utile et que ça n'est pas un travail qui
profite à l'usagé final mais nous nous y
soumettons et nous nous y soumettons en
envoyant vous imaginez bien que quand on
fait entre 800 millions et 1 milliard
d'euros d'investissements par an ça
représente une quantité très
considérable de marché transmis chaque
année et que ça représente un travail
très considérable pour l'art affaire qui
n'a d'ailleurs globalement rien trouvé à
redire aux conditions de dévolution des
marchés d'autant que tout cela est déjà
vérifier en amont par la dgccrf par les
commerciaux de marché ou qu'elles
assiègent les choisis dans l'est
la dgccrf je sais pas s'ils ont raison
ils ont pas les moyens je pense humains
suffisants pour pouvoir contrôler cela
mais sans pression à toutes les
connaissances locales en tout cas oui
mais c'est pas pour ça qu'ils ont et des
bases de données des banques de données
suffisantes le la rt1 puisque vous
l'appelez l'art a fermé aujourd'hui
c'est l'alerté
la rt a besoin de se constituer au
contraire des bases de données des
données suffisantes et c'est vrai que
l'analyse des marchés réalisée permet
effectivement de valider les estimations
qui sont faites ultérieurement
parce que si vous n'avez pas
suffisamment de recul sur beaucoup de
marchés
c'est sûr qu'après vous fait confiance à
des experts indépendants qui sont
certains plus optimistes d'autres plus
pessimistes et autres ce qui fait qu'il
ya des différences alors que là vous
avez des données réelles qui vous
permettent de mieux évaluer les
estimations des travaux futurs à
réaliser donc moi je pense que c'est pas
inutile que la l'autorité de régulation
des transports puisse avoir ses
informations et puissent s'en servir
pour bien estimer les les travaux à
venir
je suis pas sûr que mon commentaire soit
très utile je crois que les travaux
publics sont une activité cyclique dont
les prix varient ce ne suis pas du tout
convaincu de l'intérêt qu'il y à
constituer des bibliothèques de prix
parce que même si vous évaluer le prix
de la tonne d'enrobé nice
et que vous le comparer au prix de la
tonne d'enrobé à angers selon que vous
êtes proche d'une carrière ou que le
prix du pétrole et du bitume auront
évolué les prix peuvent varier de 30 ou
40 % à la même période et donc je ne
crois pas du tout à l'utilité de la
mercuriale des prix que veut constituer
la raf est et je pense que c'est un
travail de titan dont je doute de
l'utilité mais ça ne m'appartient pas
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire au
président romand mais libre libre à lui
pour le reste je crois que le rôle de
l'art à faire et c'est d'ailleurs ce que
dit le président romand est d'apporter
de la clarté de la transparence et de la
compréhension sur une activité dont la
largeur et la complexité rendent parfois
les choses difficiles à apercevoir à
qu'il n'investit pas suffisamment de
temps et donc je crois que le rôle de
l'art affaire devenue à rt est très
utile à la fois dans la compréhension et
dans le l'explication du modèle des
concessions
je ne pense pas mais par contre j'ai sa
question
je veux faire humblement le porte
parolat de notre collègue sénatrice
christine lagarde donc sa question et je
souhaite connaître le fonctionnement
économique des aires d'autoroute les
concessionnaires
en tout cas groupe vinci est il
intéressé vinci autoroutes est il
intéressé au chiffre d'affaires réalisé
dans ces espaces et pour troisième point
comment sont choisis les exploitants de
pompe à essence de restaurants et
l'ensemble des prestataires de services
qui sont et qui travaille sur les aires
autoroutières voilà la question de
christine lagarde
nous sommes dans notre mission de
concessionnaires chargé de du
fonctionnement des déserts et de
d'assurer sur je crois que nous avons
180 6 heures de service d'assurer 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
la distribution du carburant la
restauration et la boutique
ainsi que les sanitaires et un ensemble
de services j'ai beaucoup investi depuis
2006 sur l'amélioration des services sur
les airs avec le souci de rompre avec le
restoroute historique dont on a tous des
souvenirs émus de la médiocre qualité et
en installant des marques de
centre-ville des systèmes de
restauration moderne et une offre à la
fois diversifiée et qualitative de
restauration et je pense que nous avons
réussi au fil des renouvellements de
contrats de sous concession a grandement
amélioré les offres le concessionnaire
est intéressé à cette activité avec des
redevances qui le perçoit sur les sous
concessionnaire qu'il soit pétrolier
restaurateurs ou sur les boutiques
redevances qui permettent d'assurer
notamment les charges d'exploitation de
maintenance et de nettoyage des
installations annexes
nos installations commerciales dont on
est le plus souvent gestionnaires et les
exploitants sont choisis par appel
d'offres c'est une activité
étonnamment réglementé qui est très
encadrée par l'état 13 suivie par la rt
alors qu'elle est très commercial et qu'
on pourrait avoir confiance dans le
développement de l'activité et des
ventes pour réguler cette activité une
fois acté les principes de continuité
d'ouverture 7 jours sur 7 24 heures sur
mais cette activité est très contrôlé
très régulée très suivie avec des délais
de sous-concession encadré et un
contrôle à la fois de la dgitm et de la
rp puis in fine et génère de la lourdeur
administrative mais une assez bonne
[Musique]
prestation et un bon niveau de qualité
je revendique l'amélioration que nous
avons obtenus et puisque
vous me tendez la perche j'ai plaisir à
vous dire que nous avons obtenu de notre
partenaire total qu'il expérimente sur
deux aires de service un processus
innovant de distribution de carburant
low cost avec son enseigne total access
et je pense que ce sera particulièrement
appréciée de nos clients et nous
inaugurerons ça à partir du 1er juillet
mais c'est un scoop pour aujourd'hui
merci du scoop
y at il d'autres questions se rapportant
aux résidents peut-être une dernière
question sur le
j'ai vu dans le rapport financier que
les rémunérations des dirigeants des
entreprises étaient en fait porté par
les maisons mères
quand est ce que j'ai compris de
l'analyse des documents financiers
j'imagine que ces rémunérations font
l'objet de refacturation par la maison
mère aux sociétés sont de vrais normal
et y at il d'autres prestations qui font
l'objet de refacturation des services du
siège qui sont apportées et donc je vous
en ai demandé un peu le détail sur les
dernières années donc je pense que
savons-nous je fournirai mais est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire un petit peu ce
qui est ce que quelles sont les
prestations qui sont fournies par a
parlé de sièges aux sociétés
d'autoroutes oui alors je vous confirme
qu'il ya un système de facturation
comme dans tout l'est dans tous les
groupes des coûts qui sont supportés par
les différentes structures je vous
confirme je suis salarié de du groupe et
je vous confirme que c'est évidemment
des charges refacturées je vous confirme
que d'autres charges sont refacturés qui
sont qui relève notamment des
prestations de conseil ou de prise en
charge de compétences particulières
notamment sur les questions de
financement
c'est un sujet qui fait l'objet
effectivement d'une question écrite que
vous m'avez posé et dont la réponse
précise est en cours d'élaboration dans
le cadre des délais que vous m'avez
accordé jusqu'au 30 juin merci pas
d'autres questions je me tourne vers la
régie pour pas de collègues visio en
visio qui souhaitent poser une question
bien nous allons clore
cette audition en vous remerciant de
votre participation en sciant les
sénateurs présents ici et au sénat dans
la salle clémenceau et nos collègues
sénateurs et sénatrices présente en
visio merci et à tout à l'heure pour la
deuxième séance d'audition merci enfin
à
[Musique]